This part of the request is
called the header section,
as it contains the headers.
Headers are additional data
about the request itself.
A lot of these headers
are standardized
and contain information
like what type of browser
is making the request, what kind
of format the browser supports,
and what version of
the document is already
available in the
browser's local cache.
All of these
headers are optional
except for the host header.
The smallest request
that can be made
would only consist of the
first line and a host header.
At a first glance,
a response looks
very similar to a request.
The biggest difference is
probably the first line.
Here you can find
out the status code
of the response that indicates
if your request was fulfilled
successfully, if the
document was not found,
or if the server wants to
redirect you somewhere else.
Just like with the
request, the next section
is the header section.
It not only contains
data about the document,
but also about the server
and the connection.
Again, most of these
headers are optional.
The only obligatory header
is content-length to tell
the client how many bytes
of data it should expect.
After the headers and an
additional empty line,
the actual document is sent.
This can be a JPEG
image an HTML document
or whatever you want to
transfer to the user.